Alors petit conseil pour bien savourer cette vidéo
je vous recommande d'aller voir l'original avant sur ma chaîne YouTube
elle s'appelle chat en mission aller, bon visionnage
*Musique*
ça va être compliqué Merlin coopère pas du tout
et là il a pas du tout envie de jouer enfaite
donc début de tournage plûtot complexe
ok Henri je suis entrain de tester cette caméra que j'ai récupérer
ça fait deux ans que je l'ai pas sortie
et tu as l'honneur d'être le premier plan
C'est quoi c'est une DV ?
*bruit bitbox*
C'est le premier plan du making-off ont est entrain d'écrire la vidéo enfaite
Et là-bas il y a Vincent
Qui est vraiment au bout de l'image *rire*
Écriture de la vidéo
C'est fait dans un appart' ou genre avec les moyens du bord, non?
Oui c'est trop marrant
Bah uii
On va mettre les deux livres et il fait le grand écart tu vois ?
*RIRES*
Vincent, va nous dévoiler le story board qu'on a encore jamais vu nous de notre côté
Tu vois l'anannas qui vole ?
Il est où l'ananas ?
Là *rire*
Oh punaise !
Tu vois ça ?
C'est ta carrière
NaaA !! *bruit de lancement d'ananas* ;)
Explosion en détail
Je vais la faire exploser
Merlin beaucoup trop bien déssiné
Extrêmement mignon ^-^
Vous décorez tout ou ...?
Non, j'aime juste bien dessiner donc j'ai tout dessiné